dirty water hotdogs that's what we do
[Music]
when traveling to New York for the first
time
ask yourself what any traveler should
ask going anywhere for the first time
with especially if they have limited
time there what do they do there that is
unique to that place that they
inarguably do better than anybody else
in the world now we have a lot of really
great great French restaurants and
european-style restaurants here some of
the best in the world but if you're only
in New York for two or three days why
would you want to do that what are we
the best stop what do we have that you
definitely do not have I'll tell you we
have good deli we have better deli than
you so I would go to Russ & Daughters or
pastrami queen or Katz as I get myself a
good pastrami sandwich on rye with some
sour pickles but dr. Brown's cream soda
I'd get a toasted bialy
or a good-quality bagel with some nice
smoked salmon on it and some cream
cheese I would eat some utility pizza
maybe it's not the best pizza in the
world that is New York Pizza is a unique
working-class universal experience I
would do that dirty water hotdogs that's
what we do yeah I like a dirty water
hotdogs as much as anybody else it's not
the best hotdogs in the world by any
stretch of the imagination if I was
looking for the best hotdogs in the
world I probably look at a Chicago